- Welcome back, y'all, we're
here with Chrissy Teigan
and David Chang!
(audience applauds)
Together they've got a new show
called "Chrissy & Dave Dine Out".
You can see it Wednesdays on Freeform
and streaming the next day on Hulu.
The show covers a bunch of
different categories of food
so it's time to test how
well Chrissy and I...
I will not, but I know some
of those different categories-
- Girl, I am not good at games.
- You know food!
Anyway, this is "Quick Quick Categories".
♪ Quick Quick Categories ♪
- [Kelly] Okay!
- [Chrissy] There we go,
Quick Quick Categories.
- Oh my gosh!
From that vocal I got hints
of, remember "Hercules"?
The singers on the "Hercules" soundtrack?
I love it!
Gave me those vibes, you
should check it out, anyway...
Thank you for hosting.
I know that you're so excited about it.
- I was born for this moment, yeah.
(David laughs)
- Alright, tell us, here we go.
- Alright folks, in this
game I will give a category
of something that has to do with food,
might be brands of food,
might be types of restaurants.
Kelly and Chrissy will
take turns naming things
within that specific category.
When someone gets one
wrong, repeats an answer,
or takes longer than
three seconds to answer,
you'll hear this sound:
(buzzer sounds)
- I'm gonna throw up.
(audience laughs)
(Chrissy laughs nervously)
- I don't even understand
the rules, so I am like...
- If you get the buzzer,
that means the other person
gets the point.
I also don't understand what's going on.
(Chrissy laughs)
- Should go great.
- Kelly is playing to win a prize
for the left of the audience.
(left side of audience cheers)
Chrissy is playing for the
right side over by the band.
(right side of audience cheers)
- Are you guys ready?
- Yes!
- Eh...
- Alright, category one.
- Okay.
- [David] Chrissy starts.
"Kitchen Appliances".
- Oh, food processor.
- Blender.
- Why you looking at me?
(David and the audience laugh)
- Ice cream maker.
- Ice maker.
Ah, cheated, kinda.
- A Ninja.
Is that a..?
- Kind of a blender but yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
So, um...
So, an oven.
(buzzer sounds)
- Oh!
Oh my God, we won!
(audience cheers)
I know for a fact you let me have that
because you are so good at games
- You should know me better than that,
I don't let anyone win.
I don't even let my seven year old win!
- Alright, category two.
Kelly, ready?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- "Soft Drink Brands".
- Oh, Dr. Pepper.
- That's my favorite!
Coke.
- Pepsi.
- Mountain Dew.
- Sprite.
- Squirt.
- Fanta.
(audience laughs)
- La Croix.
- Oh, (beep).
Dr. Thunder!
It's the off-brand...
- The off-brand Dr. Pepper?
(buzzer sounds)
(audience cheers)
That's what my mom would buy-
- That's what we would buy!
- Next category.
- Chrissy, "Shapes of Pasta".
Shapes of pasta.
- Fusilli.
- What?
(audience laughs)
Penne.
- Bucatini.
- Spaghetti.
- Lasagna.
- Angel hair.
- That's a good one.
Cavatappi.
(David laughs)
- She heard me!
- Cavatelli.
- You said it wrong!
- Cavatelli!
- Yes!
(buzzer sounds)
(audience cheers)
- What's cavatappi?
Cavatappi!
You never had a cavatappi?
- Here is the thing, I didn't know,
so you could've gotten away with it.
- I just remembered Fusilli
Jerry from "Seinfeld"
and that's, like, my only reference.
- Alright, Kelly, category:
"Foods That Start with The Letter J".
- Jackfruit.
- That's really good and very Asian.
- [Kelly] Okay.
(audience laughs)
- Jam.
(David laughs)
- Jell-O.
(Kelly gasps)
(buzzer sounds)
(audience cheers)
- I still can't think of one.
- I don't know either, jam...
- [Kelly] Jelly bean!
- Jelly bean.
- I was sticking with Jell-O.
- [Chrissy] Once you get it, yeah...
- I don't know.
(air horn blares)
(Kelly imitates air horn)
- Last category, last category.
- You're killing it, by the way, dude.
- I'm gonna honestly throw up.
- "Fast Food Restaurants".
- Oh yeah, baby!
Burger King!
- Taco Bell.
- McDonald's.
- Whataburger.
- Del Taco.
- Dairy Queen.
(Chrissy and the audience laugh)
- A&W.
- KFC.
- Popeye's.
- Oh, good!
Chicken Express.
- Shake Shack.
- Oh, (beep), Schlotzsky's.
- Chick-fil-A.
- Is Shake Shack a fast food?
- Yes, yes, yes.
- Oh, okay.
And then, sorry, Taco Bueno.
- El Pollo Loco?
- Kinda.
- [David] It's not Jeopardy.
- Okay, oh, Wendy's.
- Oh that's a good one.
Oh, no, no, no, no...
(Chrissy babbles anxiously)
(buzzer sounds)
- Yes!
(air horns blare)
Finally!
That's when being a
closet fat kid works out!
That's all I'm saying!
♪ Yeah ♪
You ain't gonna beat me!
You're too scared to beat me at fast food!
(Chrissy and the audience laugh)
Everyone, everyone wins on
the Kelly Clarkson Show!
Millions rely on Yelp
to connect with trusted local businesses
from restaurants to home services.
This week, Yelp announced
their top 100 places to eat
in the country.
So, you can dine at your
favorite restaurant.
Yelp is giving everyone
here $200 Visa gift cards!
(audience cheers)
Watch "Chrissy & Dave Dine
Out" Wednesdays on Freeform,
and streaming next day on Hulu!